oh man so I got to get a haircut I gotta
get my hair highlighted that's stained
his cage for at least two hours we've
been working him up to just staying in
there by himself so far so good he's
been sleeping through the night which is
great but I'm making sure that he has
some nice sweet tunes to listen to well
I'm gone we got some Paul Luke here for
you Matt has been real into a DJ snake
he likes martin garrix he is ruling to
Paul Luke but yo he's a DJ so he's his
musical tastes but they very alright
here's my before hair before
prepare yourself for after and after did
you like my new haircut can you even
tell if it's any different he's like how
can I get all of my toys how's any be
touching all my coins at the same time
he was so much taller to do really is
1.3 pounds Maddie look at your head
I'm getting sleepy
look at you he's like can I go home now
I'm tired hey guys why I'm off to
Pittsburgh right now and I'm so sad
because the first time I got to leave my
little man are you gonna miss me
Leila and pitar gonna be here to take
care of you he doesn't even care that
I'm gonna be leaving he's like you fed
me all as well I get to go see Bo both
your little I guess you'd be a proper
housing be your cousin maybe some sort
of dog relative okay I gotta go I'm late
I'm late as always
hello
dwelling fresh-faced Twila brush face
young so I didn't sleep last night I
have to have a video due to be reviewed
to make sure that was located but I
wasn't traveling I could have shot it
today but traveling so it would be a
shoot as I shoot repetitive all night
did sleep I slept five and older was
really cool
I miss Maddie I miss him so much I just
like the game does a live cam and I'm
just like what is ready he's sleeping
nicely back do days later got him taking
good care by the way there's I go can I
miss you so much honey what am I going
to give you I want to see my snake head
of my green yeah I'm number three hurry
up till dawn and then which slated in
Phoenix
oh I'm receiving photos of Maddie and
using his little training class and he's
doing so good Jenna's on a call you're a
mess yeah I think awarding rewarding
good we got a rule C in Pittsburgh guys
Bri come on Bri come you're hi Bri Bri
where's Paul I'm really upset I told
them we were gonna be seen Bo today
guess we're not saying Bo free say hi to
the Internet hi we missed you yep yeah
you excited for the big game tomorrow
big game blue who's your favorite player
you need my color that's what I said you
having in your fantasy no I got Ben I
have Jimi green are you projected first
yep you pick a plus a plus
I was injected wise now I'm projected
last I made really a mistake but I did
some switches it's okay because
projections don't mean anything what I
keep telling us I mean everything I've 8
plus yeah I don't little vlog here a
couple little clips of Maddie oh my
goodness I seriously I miss him so much
like I'm losing my mind it's gonna be so
hard to ever leave him when I travel um
but yeah I I'm wearing a Slayer shirt
right now so so there's that I was
looking for a t-shirt I was like well
you know what this is what is happening
oh my goodness my phones blowing up
let's group chats
do you guys ever get stuck in a group
chat where you're you can't like well I
mean I want to be a part of it but if
things just start happening I'm gonna go
to sleep now because it's I've been over
24 hours since I slept last maybe longer
I don't remember I don't feel well I
definitely don't feel well but I'm sad
if the Steeler game so if any of you
guys are there tweet me we're gonna be
doing something really fun so you may
see me
somewhere bye good boy oh you did a
quick one it was like a quick like look
I'm sitting